Here's some code for finding the second largest name in that list.
It starts off opening the file that has the year of birth 1995 data in it
and instead of having just one max value that they're keeping track of
we keep track of the max name and the maximum value we've seen so far
and the second highest name and value that we've seen so far.
I initialized to zero because all of the values in this file are greater than zero,
actually five or greater, and then, we loop through the lines in the file,
for each line, we pull out the name, sex, and count using rsplit
and make sure that that count is not a string anymore but an integer,
and we check to make sure the sex is female
because that's the way we're doing it for this question.
If the count of this new person that we just encountered, this new name,
is bigger than the best we've seen so far then what we're going to do
is take what used to be the best so far and move it to the second best.
What used to be the best is now going to get filled in with the current individual.
On the other hand, if the count is not bigger than the largest we've seen so far,
but it is bigger than the second largest we've seen so far,
then we just replace the second largest we've seen so far.
When this loop is all completed, and we've ran through all the names,
we just print the value and name that has the maximum
and the value of the name has the second maximum.
We can run this, and we can see that Jessica is the highest valued name,
and Ashley is the second highest.